alright guys you just watched my basic
plan the overview this is video 2 we're
going to dig into some more of the
details this is mainly for people that
are new to my channel again I have 2500
videos and if you can get lost in all
the details this is the second video
that you should watch and we're
combining a healthy keto within a minute
fasting okay alright number one you want
to go as long as you can in the morning
without eating you just don't want to
eat unless you're hungry that's the the
thing that you need to focus on because
so many people eat when they're not
hungry and they're wondering why it's
not working they're not getting results
because the body finally is burning fat
and then you start eating what will
happen is you're gonna raise insulin and
then if your instants gonna come high
and then it's gonna push your blood
Sugar's low then you're gonna be hungry
an hour and a half later
so really it's what you ate the night
before that's gonna dictate if you're
hungry in the morning if you do this
correctly like I'm showing you with just
two meals a day you're gonna wake up in
the morning not hungry so the goal is to
go as long as you can you may find that
you can't go all the way to lunch you
have to eat it like 11 o'clock fine eat
your breakfast there okay but what will
happen you want to keep pushing it to
the point where your your body is fully
adapted to fat-burning you're no longer
sugar burning that could take three days
up to five days sometimes it takes
longer to get into full ketosis alright
so that's the first rule of thumb if we
can do two meals with a four-hour window
okay and what that means is that we eat
and then we wait for hours and we eat
again that's your window that will give
you a 20 hour fasting period that's
incredible that's enough to see some
serious results the only time that would
not work for someone as far as weight
loss goes is let's say they're going
through menopause they have a slow
thyroid condition and they have a
history of dieting and their metabolism
is so slow they're gonna have to push
these together
have one meal a day and then they will
lose weight and there are even people
that still will lose just a little bit
on this and they might need to go even
longer because their metabolism is so
dead and I've had this happen not to a
lot of people but certain people that
just you know from birth they just had a
slow metabolism for one thing or another
and they need to go like probably eat
every other day okay that's just what
they need to do until the system heals
but for everyone else we're going to
talk about what are you gonna eat on
this first meal and the second meal I've
surveyed a lot of people and this is
what they eat and this is what I hate
eggs I do four eggs a day you can do 2
to 4 eggs pasture-raised or organic eggs
they're a little more expensive but
they're worth it now it's really
important to eat healthy eggs because
the factory farm eggs are just so bad
they're just terrible then we have
avocado avocado has tremendous amount of
potassium and really good fats to help
you go longer
she's now if you are a guy and you have
a prostate condition don't do the cheese
but if you have a high quality organic
cheese from a grass-fed cow goat's
cheese is even better not a problem okay
so then we have bacon some people don't
want to do bacon that's totally fine I
like bacon I do bacon from the farmers
market if you're gonna go to a huffin
store get the nitrate free Organic bacon
with with sugars less than one gram okay
bacon by the way and pork has high
levels of vitamin b1 and for those
people are saying bacon is unhealthy yet
they're consuming chicken I would beg to
differ because chicken is really
disgusting unless you're doing again
from the farmers market okay nut butters
you can do almond butter peanut butter
make sure there's no sugar in it maybe a
couple of tablespoons now the reason for
this is to give you enough fat
especially in the beginning so you can
go longer okay without getting hungry
you know you're eating at 12 you have a
hamburger or a piece of meat or any a
lamb or whatever meat that you want
three to six ounces let's say you're
younger and you have a faster metabolism
then you do eight ounces let's say for
example you're an athlete you do eight
ounces let's say you're a very large
person you need more protein do eight
ounces I wouldn't want to go over eight
ounces per meal now we're not talking
about actual protein grams we're talking
about the actual product of meat itself
okay three to six ounces or eight ounces
so you don't have to calculate the grams
inside that meat but it is a big
difference and then we consume our
vegetables you can steam them you can
have some raw or the salad I do a lot of
salads we need a large amount of salad
so some people break up their salad
between this meal here in this meal and
they do maybe five cups and five cups or
maybe four cups and four cups I mean
four cups is not that that much it's
just it's kind of like a medium sized
salad I personally do all of my salad at
one sitting I'll do like ten cups and
sometimes I'll do more than that so I'm
used to it
if you feel worse with consuming those
greens that means that you're microbes
are not quite in the right place you
might have a condition called SIBO I'll
put a link down below in which case you
want to cut back on your vegetables
because what's gonna happen the fiber in
the vegetable is going to retain fluid
and you're gonna feel bloated and you're
gonna your weight loss is not gonna come
off it's not because you're not losing
weight it's because you're retaining
fluid okay just realize you want to feel
good after consuming this and you may
have to eat small amounts and gradually
increase it because guess who's eating
your the fiber from your vegetables the
microbes and they might not be plentiful
enough to do that so there's many
different reasons I'll put a video down
below just on that one topic olive oil
balsamic vinaigrette is a great dressing
maybe a handful of nuts some seeds
because we want that fat so this is like
one option of a meal this is another
option of meal just to give you an
example I put a link down below to my
website because I have a lot of
different examples of different meals I
have a whole recipe but this would be an
example of a typical meal for someone
okay let's say you do fish I love salmon
is one of the best proteins because it
has omega-3 we want to do quality
protein so you can also do sardines
believe it or not there are good fats in
sardines I did a video on that for
seafood
okay this gives you the iodine so you do
your fish or seafood your salad this is
for your dinner and a fat bomb what is
the fat bomb it's like a little cookie
with healthy fats in it you can make
recipes for this a lot of people consume
the fat bomb just to get them satisfied
so they can go from one meal to the next
as your body adapts to fat burning you
probably won't even need that because
you're burning your own fat but in the
beginning it's really helpful here's
another option for some food you can do
chicken with the skin preferably nice
and crispy or chicken wings let's say
you do again treat it 6 ounces of
chicken and chicken wings do your
protein it's moderate protein asparagus
ok or any other vegetable that you like
or your salad and then you do olives as
your fat okay
I do a lot of nuts myself I do that
after the meal to the point where I'm
like really satisfied so I can go longer
but the key is not snacking at night so
you want to add enough fat to go from
this meal all the way to breakfast now
the number one weakness people have I
just realized was boredom so you're
gonna have to keep really busy right
here and make sure you're not bored so
you don't eat the wrong thing you can
consume your vitamins it's not a problem
any time of the day apple cider vinegar
teaspoon and some lemon is really good
to have when you drink water coffee in
the morning try to just do one you can
do tea you can add some bulletproof
that's a MCT oil coconut oil you can put
that blend that in your drink if you
want especially in the beginning to
allow you to go without having the first
meal
not a problem but if you find that that
slows down your weight loss as you do
this over a period of a couple weeks and
you might want to drop out the extra fat
urged a snack that means you need more
fat and more greens more vegetables
those two things will solve the problem
if you crave bread you need more B
vitamins I recommend electrolytes a good
powder
B vitamins and or nutritional yeast you
can get them in tablets very important
just to make this transition smooth so
you have no problems C so don't be
afraid to add more sea salt because
you're gonna need more salt you're gonna
dump more fluid on this program and so
you have to replace it
the best time to exercise is when you're
fasting so in the morning okay it's
actually you get better benefits realize
that it could take longer to adapt but
the way that you know you're in hardcore
ketosis is that you crave nothing
you're not even hungry anymore that's
when you know what's really working
better than any other test this should
give you the next layer of information
or knowledge you need to know and I will
see you in the third video if you're
liking this content please subscribe now
and I will actually keep you updated on
future videos